les 915 la guerre terroriste s'enrichit
d'un nouvel exploit
un bateau neutre et torpillé par un
sous-marin son nom le lusitanien
les anglais aussi on en construit des
sous marins john fisher
le prédécesseur de chukchi d'un admis
rod est lui bien conseillé d'utiliser
ces fischer treuil
mais les sous marins anglais ne coule
pas les bateaux neutre il ne faut pas de
guerre terroriste tirpitz l'amiral
constructeur de la flotte allemande a
convaincu l'empereur d'en construire
quelques-uns
depuis 1900 les sous-marins sortent des
usines krupp
on en vend même aux russes les modèles
construit en 1914 ne sont pas des petits
engins défensif mais déjà les vaisseaux
conçus pour des courses à longue portée
mais également en en 28 ce type
j'aurai une flotte de 33 les anglais en
ont 74 mais seulement 10 mythes sont
capables de s'élever médicaux la subir
vérité des mots deuxièmement a été
démontrée
en septembre 1914 un unaf un sous marin
allemand a coulé trois vieux croiseur
britannique la boue qui en log et le
crds et si ça a été une émotion
considérable à londres
le sous-marin les avait surpris au large
de la côte landaise la bouillir avait
coulé en 25 minutes
ses compagnons de route s'était arrêté
pour recueillir les survivants lui neuf
avec nouveau frappé mille quatre cents
marins étaient morts
l'amirauté avait envoyé de nouveaux
ordres aucun navire nous devait
s'arrêter pour recueillir désormais des
naufragés qu'ils se débrouillent seuls
voici le seul torpillage films et de la
guerre c'est un oeil 35
un sous marin allemand qui quittent
trieste pour aller à la chasse aux
canards
c'est ainsi qu'on appelle les cargos a
lié son commandant arnaud perrier est un
descendant de huguenots français
c'est un fanatique de cinéma et il
compte bien filmé à bord de sous-marins
ses propres exploits
une 35 opère toujours en surface il
respecte le droit de la guerre
le capitaine a pour mission d'arrêter
les navires marchands et de vérifier
s'il se livre tous non à la contrebande
d armes avant de les couler au canon ou
capital ordonne l'évacuation de
l'équipage
un naufrage ou bâle l'action exemplaire
le capitaine peut montrer son film il en
est assez fier
les jours suivants le commandant de
périers en schiste série de succès ils
coulent successivement le maple wood
chargé de minerai de fer qui allait de
tunis londres lyndia chargés de charbon
de cardiff en iran et le stromboli
transportant du fer de baltimore à jane
mais ces scores fleuves dans le gène
était bourré de fer et d'acier mais
c'est ce nom pour livrer à gènes du blé
américain
le blé est une matière stratégique c'est
discutable la dernière cible est un
chômeur un trois mâts le miss maurice
thévenet de madagascar avec une
cargaison qui n'avait absolument rien de
stratégique
c'était uniquement des tortues
m
après seulement deux célèbres bruyamment
ses succès à l'est situé en mer du nord
par méditerranée c'est bien plus
glorieux
l'état major allemand n'oublie jamais la
propagande de guerre
un problème je push bientôt faut-il
continuer à raisonner en surface en bref
dans l'équipage ou bien couler les
bateaux de commerce par des torpilles en
naviguant sous l'eau sans avertissement
d'aucune chante depuis octobre 1914 la
flotte anglaise renforce le blocus de
l'allemagne dans la chapelle et la mer
du nord
le but est évidemment d'un femme est
l'ennemi de l'empêcher de produire un
tout petit couloir est réservé à la
navigation des neutres en février 1915
les allemands réplique déclare zone de
guerre toutes les côtes des îles
britanniques
les navires marchands et demi seront
cool et sans avertissement
les neutres sont en danger car les
navires britanniques sont soupçonnés de
naviguer sous pavillon ne scandale on
admet l'idée de frapper un navire
marchand désarmer et de ne pas secourir
l'équipage
c'est du terrorisme grande bretagne on
mesure le danger
le pays peut résister à ce blocage
sauvage pendant trois mois au plus
pourtant l'action des sous-marins et
décevante en mai 10 215 ils ont coulé
seulement 51 des 15000 navire qui
entrent dans les ports anglais
la flotte des chalutiers passe au
travers pas de victime parmi eux
les allemands sont furieux le trafic
commercial semble défier les red sous
marins alors que quelques navires
marchands seulement peuvent défier des
champs de mines britannique qui longe
les côtes allemandes
ils ne veulent pas convenir que les
mines sont plus efficaces et moins
répréhensible que leurs sous marins
à
e
l'allemagne les effets du blocus sont
vivement ressenti on estime qu'avant un
an le pays connaîtra des émeus but à la
famine et des scènes de pillage des
stocks militaires peut être même des
mutineries
non
les prises alimentaires risquent de
flamber ils ont déjà augmenté de 83% à
berlin le 112 % à vienne pelé pommes de
terre sont contingentées les mardis et
les vendredis la population ne peut
acheter de viande chaque allemand touche
un oeuf par personne et par semaine ont
fait la queue pour avoir du beurre ou de
margarine le rationnement est encore
renforcée les allemands sont arrivés
l'échéance de la famine et envisage des
représailles rapide et efficace il lance
des meutes de sous marins sur la flotte
anglaise
entends bhl en dhr allemand de guerre
totale les neutres et particulièrement
les états unis sont alignés ainsi on
pourra torpiller les navires marchands
sans sommation c'est une violation des
lois degré que tous les pays civilisés
ont accepté un retrait d'allemagne des
lois d'humaniser la guerre les allemands
prétendent que les notes sont épargnés
le lusitanien n'est pas un bateau neutre
il bat pavillon britannique
c'est l'orgueil de la canarde white star
line
il a été lancé en écosse sur les
chantiers de la clyde en 1907 il pèse 30
mille tonnes est poussé machine 25
valeurs
il a battu le record de vitesse sur
l'atlantique détenues précédemment par
un paquebot allemand le touch lente
le lusitanien est dotée de machines
d'une puissance très supérieure
il a pris le ruban bleu aisément en 1907
il a parcouru la distance de queenstown
en irlande jusqu'à new york
en quatre jours et demi pour cette
époque et sur la distance c'est un
record c'est une des merveilles du xxème
siècle comble du luxe un palace flottant
décor et flamboyant selon le goût de
l'époque un pesant chef-d'oeuvre
subventionné par le gouvernement
resplendissant de chrome d'acajou d'une
bourde de draperies de velours
d'ascenseur de cabine téléphonique
impliqué électrique dans les cabines
d'un début des reconditionnés la salle à
manger des premières et du pur 8,16
surmonté d'un dôme où batifolent l'élu
spat la chaufferie a une capacité de
7000 tonnes avec 25 chaudière et d'une
nouvelle turbine à vapeur sur le pont le
capitaine william turner 59 ans ce loup
de mer en fin de carrière commande le
plus fantastique le plus rapide et le
plus sûr bateau lui manque
lincou lab lusitanien
1er mai 1915 à new york samedi matin
quand les journaux on peut lire la danse
du film de griffes qui vient de sortir
naissance d'une nation les grands
magasins bloomingdale's fond de la
réclame pour la canne de marche prince
de galles ou pour les pianos là une
petite annonce attire l'attention elles
émanent de l'ambassade d'allemagne à la
verte il public américain que les
navires battant pavillon anglais peuvent
être cool et sans avertissement
les voyageurs doivent prendre leur
risques en soie mâle ans est scandaleuse
elle condamne les voyageurs américains
un voyage est exclusivement sous leur
pavillon alors qu'ils ne sont pas en
guerre et qu'ils ont le choix des
navires
sur la juste numéro 54 au pied de la 11e
rue au coeur du district alimentaire on
retarde le départ du lusitania jusqu'à
12h30 13 cents passagers s'impatiente
parmi eux 129 enfants sans compter les 6
200 marins les passagers de première
classe ou payés 137 dollars quelques uns
seulement d'annuler le capitaine turner
affecte de mépriser dabo n'a seulement
c'est dit il la plus belle plaisanterie
que j'ai entendue depuis longtemps il a
tout à fait confiance dans son avis sur
les listes de la cargaison le seul
indice de contrebande 4200 caisses de
munitions pour armes individuelles
un bruit court le navire transporterait
6 millions de dollar en par le manifeste
ne le mentionne pas autre rumeur le
navire serait armé les britanniques
démentent
le receveur du port de new york qui
visitent le navire avant son
appareillage d'aimantation tour 159
citoyens américains sont à bord
parmi eux le philosophe albert labarde
et se femme alice le célèbre producteur
child froman
le propriétaire d'une écurie de course
van der bilt cent fois millionnaire qui
va visiter ces écuries londonienne on
largue les amarres leurs caisses du bord
joue qui paiera riz et le star spangled
banner avec les choeurs des royals wesh
à
tout d'un coup l'enfant périscope le
capitaine d'un sous marin allemand a vu
20 aperçoit le lusitanien lully tanière
n'y prend pas garde
il n'a aucun navire d'accompagnement
pour le prévenir
le commandant du sous marin et le
capitaine lieutenant valter schweiger
c'est sa première patrouille il vient de
couler trois navires en 48 heures pirès
seulement 3 torpille dans le vin cette
lente et que les routes de lui l'italien
et de lui vint convergent le capitaine
turner a reçu l'ordre de zigzaguer il y
répugne
il ne veut pas effrayer les passagers
dit il
il vient de recevoir enfin l'information
que 2 u boat croisait dans les parages
il réduit cependant sa vitesse à dix
mineurs pour profiter des courants
porteurs à deux heures le 7 mai 1915
schweiger aperçoit une forme noire il
plonge la base du bateau tourner
il présente son côté tribord je ne peux
pas le manquer dit il fun la torpille
éclate dans la chambre des shows lien
en 18 minutes le lusitanien coups par
trois mille pieds de fonds à 8 milles de
la côte irlandaise
où
attente anxieuse dans les offices de
l'accord de l'add on apprend que 1198
passagers ont trouvé la mort
63 sont de petits enfants 128 des
américains c'est la première fois que
les civils américains sont victimes de
la guerre alfred vanderbilt qui ne
savait pas nager avait donné sa bouée de
sauvetage à une femme née au bar tu
étais mort charles froman était mort
cette censure vivent arrivée de queen
star elle consul américain pouvait
qu'appeler les détails de la tragédie
aussi tour produit naturellement dans la
presse américaine panega queenstown des
femmes meurent très glacé les hommes
estropiés des enfants terrorisés des
piles de cadavres sur le quai
une petite annonce à la vitrine d'un
magasin
pluzz italia bébé perdu 15 mois je veux
briser est un rose un billet de jersey
blanc et de chaussons de laine blanc
essaie de parler de marché
m
et
le capitaine turner et parmi les
survivants il croyait être le dernier à
avoir abandonné le bord il avait quitté
la passerelle plonger dans l'eau lorsque
la proue émergé au-dessus de la bible
10 mai queenstown un premier groupe de
100 victimes et inhumé dans une fosse
commune
aux etats unis l'opinion est en état de
choc
le new york sun affirme que le pays n'a
pas été victime d'une telle folie
criminelle depuis la perte du cuirassé
le mène en 1898 le new york times
habituellement réservées déclare ce
n'est pas la guerre
c'est du crime
l'enquète ils ne sentent la canarde et
le capitaine dornach celui ci accuse
l'amirauté on aurait dû dit-il l'escorté
actuel répond pas question de détacher
des destroyers pour protéger des
paquebots à londres une procession
funèbre exhibe la maquette du bateau
e
dans plusieurs villes anglaises la
colère s'exprime les magasins aux noms
allemands ou qui vendent des
marchandises allemandes sont mises à sac
les bobines interviennent guerre pour
empêcher les pillages
en allemagne on édite une carte postale
qui représente le lusitanien et l'amiral
phone tirpitz comme si le torpillage du
paquebot était d'une victoire
personnelle de l'amiral allemand mais
l'empereur n'est pas à l'aise n'arrache
veut la presse américaine ne faiblit pas
un allemand d'amérique est arrêté pour
parjure
lorsqu'il a affirmé à la cour qu'il
avait vu les canons sur le lusitanien il
écope de 18 mois de prison
theodore roosevelt l'ancien président
traite le torpillage de piraterie et de
crime
wilson le président en exercice bombarde
berne 1-2 note exigeant que les citoyens
américains en mer tu à respecter
tout pouvant l'agression des sous-marins
écrit wilson sera considéré comme un
acte délibérément et namik
tennis fantastique cette réaction
beaucoup trop faible et le secrétaire
d'état brian l'estimaient au contraire
trop forte
les allemands comprennent la menace
au début de 1916 il abandonne la guerre
totale par sous marins
ils ont décidé d'employer sur le front
de l'ouest
l'autre forme de guerre terroriste
l'anéantissement par les gaz et les
cadrans lourd après la terreur sur mer
le désert près par la terreur à verdun
l'europe du nord-ouest et meurtri
l'occupation sauvage les gaz asphyxiant
les sous-marins autant manifestation de
la guerre terroriste de la guerre totale
qui frappe aussi l'angleterre
la forteresse insulaire gardé par la
plus puissante flotte du monde a été
férocement bombardé le 16 décembre 1914
par les croiseurs allemands de bataille
scarbrough oued beht hartlepool ont été
frappés
106 civils case enfants massacrés au
qanoun marine le payer choqué le défi
allemand frappe à la porte de
l'angleterre
jamais le royaume uni n'avait été
victime dans le passé d'une attaque
aussi sauvage l'opinion publique exige
des représailles sévères sur les bords
allemand l'amirauté médite sa réponse
elle veut frapper non pas les civils
mais les troupes de keyser elle veut
frapper quelque part sur les côtes du
danemark au large du jute landes
no 23 janvier 1915 premier engagement
indécis la flotte anglaise a pris la mer
pour répondre au défi des allemands les
pêcheurs n'en croient pas leurs yeux les
cuirassés lourd
les dreadlocks vont débusquer l'ennemi
dans les parages où l'on ne s'attend pas
à une bataille navale
certes pas
le dos bareback fréquenté habituellement
par des chalutiers
le superdrive ordres de l'amiral chante
avec betty a intercepté une force
allemande aura il y aura bataille
l'amiral allemand franz von biber se
dérobe conformément à sa lettre de
course il ne doit pas affronter un
ennemi supérieur ce sont les
instructions de l'amirauté allemande
les anglais sont plus rapides et mieux
armés ils comptent le plus cher mais
reçoivent eux mêmes déco et perdre
l'ennemi dans le brouillard
betty est proclamé vainqueur mais l
amirauté a des doutes sur la portée de
cette victoire qui n'est nullement
décisive
les allemands peuvent faire du mal de
retour en ville m chat fun fun hyper
reçoit l'ordre de garder sa force
intacte
plus que jamais il faut attendre que
l'ennemi prennent l'initiative et ne pas
rechercher l'engagement lui dit ans
lebara de la kriegsmarine passent leur
temps à répéter les grandes manoeuvres
et à laver le pont même mis attaquera
bien un jour ou l'autre par un anglais
restent à quai pendant toute l'année
1915 ou à bord de leurs navires
on peut se demander pourquoi le
gouvernement de sa majesté englouti
telle somme dans l'armement des supers
cuirassé ils ne prennent pas la mer la
flotte n'accomplit que des missions de
protection des côtes
le roi georges tiendra sa flotte qu'il a
lui même commandé un croiseur et c'est
certainement à bon droit que l'on
appelle cette flotte de keynes névés à
marine du roi
e
la caste sociale de la marine est
commandée par l'amiral soeur rose
leinster whims de vieille noblesse
écossaise betty est un roturier marié à
une riche américaine
le commandant de la flotte saint john
jellicoe pense après l'incident du
dogger banc que la flotte est victime de
ses traditions on peut imaginer de
nouvelles tactiques dit il de nouvelles
méthodes
il n'est plus question de grandes
batailles navales comme dans la
tradition de la royal navy
il faut prévoir et prévenir des attaques
des sous marins il ne faut pas les
mépriser
il est essentiel d'imaginer des parades
à la guerre sous-marine le des plus
sophistiqués si l'on est plus efficace
est celle des cubes haute
ces bateaux se présente comme
d'inoffensifs cargo il s'attire l'ennemi
en surface et des masques alors leur
canon pour le couler ces bateaux piège
son redoutable et surprennent au début
du moins les comores tordent et ribaute
qu'imagine qu'immédiatement des parades
la détection sous-marine on imagine un
appareil pour repérer au sont les
moteurs d'un ennemi invisible à la fin
2009 115 après la sphère du lusitanien
les sous marins allemands ont reçu une
mission nouvelle attaque et les navires
de guerre de la royal navy
désormais la grande flotte est en danger
les allemands veulent robes renforce
l'encerclement du blocus naval
ils connaissent toutes les bases
d'opérations de la navy celle de jenny
qu au nord celle de betty est aussi la
base de douvres d'où partent les
patrouilleurs et des bouilleurs de mines
dans le channel la flotte allemand de
haute mer ne sort pas un risque rien
elle se cache dans ses mouillage à
l'épreuve des mines
mais c'est uber peuvent sortir
et les zeppelins peuvent décoller ils
peuvent attaquer à la bombe
les navires de guerre en un jour ils
peuvent atteindre londres paul yamaha
wrf une fois de plus les villes
britanniques sont à la merci des raids
terroristes aux allemands après l'
attaque maritime
voici le raid aérien
les raids de ces plafonds des victimes
dans la population civile
quand ils bombardent les villes le
public et la presse exige des
représailles
la grande flotte en est chargé on attend
d'elle une action immédiate sur les
causes et demi
et
depuis le début de 1915
l'amiral s'activent il comprend que
l'opinion publique exige qu'ils
n'atterrissent le méticuleux
parcimonieux jellicoe contrôle impétueux
betty
il est convenu que bt partira seul pour
jouer le rôle d'appelants pendant que
jellicoe portera le gros de la flotte
sur les groupes danoise des hydravions
bombarderont les bases de ses plats si
des navires seulement sorte
la bataille sera décisive
à
l'amiral chez air qui commande la flotte
du désert est aventureux qui rêvent
d'engager les croiseurs de bataille de
l'amiral hyper dans un affrontement
décisif qui fasse perdre sa supériorité
à la royal navy le quai 06 veut ménager
sa flotte qui lui a coûté une fortune
mais il comprend que l'opinion ne
mettrait pas qu'elle reste au port
indéfiniment sans rien tenter
il a donné blanc sachets à erquy mehdi
une sortie il prévoit que les est plat
et sous marins seront associés à la tact
la grande flotte dès qu'elle sera
signalée en mer hyper se chargera de
l'attirer et de la conduire devant les
unités de chez ar qui attendront cad en
charge et torpilles prête au matin du 30
mai 1916 après des mois d'inaction la
grande flotte britannique quitte scapa
flow et fait route vers le sud est les
gros navires sur angelico ont fait leurs
plats de mazuch pour les plus récents le
charbon pour les autres
325 tonnes de charbon sont chargés par
350 hommes en une heure
jenny qu à lui avancé ses plans parce
qu'il a reçu l'information que la grande
flotte allemande s'apprêtait à
appareiller l'ordre a été intercepté et
décodés par les services d'intelligence
navale britannique
en réalité les allemands ont émis des
messages pour pousser bt à sortir mais
il ne pensait pas que la flotte tout
entière allait suivre bti 24 super
dreadnought sont pris la mer avec des
croiseurs de bataille des croiseurs
légers et lourds des destroyers en grand
nombre
cent cinquante deux navires obéissant
aux ordres des amiraux bts génie qu une
grande bataille navale se prépare
quelques heures plus tard sans un navire
allemand s'aligne aux ordres de hyper
qui joue le rôle de l'ape a suivi de
chair le chasseur
le 31 mai 1916 les deux grandes flottes
écume la mer du nord
chacune d'elle est à la recherche d'une
flotte et ne pensent pas tomber sur la
grande flotte
elle pourrait passer à côté d'une de
l'autre se manquer le hasard veut
qu'elle se rend compte sur le skagerak
près de la péninsule danoise du jutland
les dés sont jetés
la bataille du jutland est engagé
2h20 l'heure du destin un vapeur neutre
apparaît devant la flotte allemande dans
les jumelles d'un capitaine allemand
c'est un vapeur danois appelé le fjord
2d soyez lacoste en voir une chaloupe
pour faire une visite de contrôle
le premier échelon de la formation de bt
a aussi aperçu la vapeur du fjord des
croiseurs légers s'avance en
reconnaissance
ils sont accueillis par les canons
allemands
le galathéa indique qu'il est tout
contact biti a hyper faut ranger leur
flotte en ordre de bataille les matelots
sont réveillés par les sirènes d'urgence
il y avait aussi tout leur poste de
commande des pièces l'autre sont
aussitôt chargé près d attirer les chefs
sont impatients d'en découdre
les marins dans les tourelles ont les
nerfs à vif
oh
derrière bt l'amiral jellicoe s'approche
en tout ce sont les machines
il détache en reconnaissance 3 c'est
plus rapide croiseur de bataille il se
hâte de venir au secours de betty qui
indique en hissant son pavillon marqué
d'un lion qu'il est à la poursuite de
ipr il se précipite ainsi dans le piège
allemand toute sa flotte par suite d'une
erreur de sinnoh ne le suis pas il se
jette dans la bataille avec une partie
seulement de ces forces
moi
non
betty avance vers le sud droits sur le
piège allemand quand il reçoit un
message date ses destroyers d' approche
la flotte de bataille allemande est sur
lui
il s'agit des unités de chez air qui
chargent déjà les canaux
les navires de têtes de bétail ont de
sombre pressentiment
ils font machine arrière et rejoigne
celle aequo avec deux croiseurs de
bataille à son navire le lion qui crache
de la fumée par ses blessures
betty marmonne jure se demande ce qui
fait de la supériorité des allemands au
feu il découvre la technologie krupp et
la valeur de l'entraînement de la marine
de guerre de l'amiral phone tir pitt
tard dans l'après-midi une force
nouvelle rejoint la bataille celle avant
gardes envoyée par deux chez nikko au
secours de betty ces navires se perdent
manque l'escadre meilheureux erreur de
navigation les jette sur le flanc de la
flotte allemande
celle-ci repères mal l'ennemi dans le
brouillard et la fumée elle s'imagine
que la royal navy s'est donné rendez
vous au complet elle tire aussitôt le
canot toutes les pièces entrent en
action
les croiseurs de bataille de szczesny qu
ont accroché des demies jellicoe
lui-même surgi avec ses super
dreadnought maintenant du nord-est les
plus puissants unités sont désormais sur
les lieux veliko se désespère
d'apprendre que bt a subi de lourdes
pertes dans sa course solitaire sous le
feu du gros de l'escadre et demi
alors comment ce spectacle unique du
déploiement de la grande flotte
il est gêné par bt qui manoeuvrent
gauche mans se place entre le génie
cauet d'ennemis la fumée de ces navires
empêche l'amiral d'observer les
allemands ils envoient betty un message
excédés mais où est donc la flotte
ennemie
j'ai dit qu'on comprend que l'ennemi est
aussi embarrassé que lui et qu'il faut
profiter de la confusion à deux reprises
prenant avantage de sa vitesse
supérieure janicot lancé plus lourdes
aux unités à travers les rangs ennemis
les super red knights orgueil de la
flotte britannique
il trace une sorte de la cde noeud
coulant autour de la flotte ennemie qui
doit ainsi se trouver nécessairement
prise dans un piège dans une nasse
pour éviter le désastre l'amiral chez
air ordonne à tous ces navires de tour
med 180 degrés vers tréport
non
la flotte de haute mer s'élance en
direction de ses bases
janicot essayé de la retenir avant
qu'elle n'atteigne le sanctuaire de ses
champs de mines
avec le soleil couchant dans le dos
aveuglant les viseurs des canons
allemands les anglais se préparer au
combat à mort
le crépuscule sauve la flotte allemande
mais aussi la hardiesse de chez air qui
n'a pas la prudence tatillonne d'un
jellicoe dans l'obscurité gr conduit ses
navires à travers un couloir étroit
qu'il distingue vaguement dans une série
d'affrontements furieux dans le désordre
des bâtiments qui croisent leur route et
se reconnaissent à peine chez air
franchi l'obstacle pertes en seulement
deux croiseurs légers et un vieux navire
de bataille
j'ai dit qu'on fait son compte il a
perdu un croiseur et 5 destroyer
au matin du 1er juin 1916 et l'as wihr
britanniques découvrent que la mer est
vide
chez air fait déjà son rapport aux
kayser la supériorité britannique
n'existe plus la royal navy s'est
définitivement retirer de la guerre
la couronne la presse et le public font
à leur flotte un accueil ambiguë à son
retour en angleterre
les journaux anglais ne sont pas du tout
certain que l'amiral et gagner la
bataille et se pose le problème de kout
et de la nécessité d'un engagement aussi
dur qui n'a pas obtenu de résultats marc
attend les anglais ont perdu 14 navires
contre onze bateaux allemands 6 milles
marins sont morts et seulement 2500
allemand il n'y aurait plus dans cette
guerre de batailles navales
l'affrontement de jute landes était
inutile
il laissait le champ libre aux sous
marins
non seulement il laissait le champ libre
sous marins mais il n'avait pas remporté
la bataille décisive qui devait
interdire la mer aux escales de la
mayral volonté rhdp dit